this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by PDS debt
for thousands of years the world has
been captivated by the mystery of
Atlantis the concept of an ancient city
hidden beneath the ocean is intriguing
but what if there was not just a city
but an entire continent buried beneath
the waves the continent of lemuria is a
huge landmass believed to have sunk in
the Indian Ocean after some ancient
catastrophic event Atlantis and lemuria
are similar and that they've sparked
numerous theories Legends and
interpretations but Atlantis and lemuria
are very different in one way
there's no proof of Atlantis
[Music]
no no don't put them anywhere I didn't
order 40 palm trees
I don't care where you put them just
don't leave them at my house
I can't hear you what what do you say
hang on
hang on hey Mary close the door would
you and tell the boys to take by don't
play the union card with me Mario still
get paid for the break
she's contractors am I right contractors
what are you even what are you working
on Otis
terrarium
I know what a terrarium is what does
this have to do with me well the boys
are working on the footings for the
camel box and the terrarium and I'm a
little light on funds so I need you to
do a little teeny tiny weeny baby teeny
tiny money transfer so that it can pay
to frame Us in order to sand okay I
understand the words you're saying but
none of this makes any sense I they
guys and put in the order for the 35
cubic yards of sand 35 cubic yards how
much sand is that how about 50 tons
depending on the size of the grain
time to educate you on Sand Dunes and
these guys are still on the clock
besides I don't need the teamsters on my
dorsal fin you know what I'm talking
about again I understood the words but
did you say 50 tons of sand yeah it
might be a little less depending on the
size of the Oasis I put in and what plop
I get Palapa yeah it's a type of beach
hut I know what a Palapa is what is
going on I told you the dirty was
feeling homesick and I wanted to do
something to cheer up and you said that
I could so I'm building a terrarium in
the backyard foot it's gonna have sand
dunes and an oasis with a Palapa excuse
me and an oasis with a beach hut again I
don't know what this you should have
float me a few shackles temporarily so
they can get this thing finished yeah
but I thought you were gonna cheer up
with some hay or some flowers did you
say backyard you don't have a backyard I
have a backyard but the work is already
started the bank said I have too many
monthly payments for a construction loan
have you ever seen a depressed camel
she's just walking around in circles
like my uncle lost his left Fin and Nam
oh it's painful to watch okay okay just
slow down will you call PDS debt they
have options available for people
struggling with monthly debt payments
credit cards collections medical bills
personal loans
oh you smelled it what smells like
Today's Pizza yep if you're making
monthly payments every month and your
balances aren't going down PDS can help
they roll your debt into one low zero
percent interest monthly payment you can
save thousands in interest and fees and
pay off your debt in a fraction of the
time yeah but I have a lot of debt and
my credit score is not awesome alimony
shows up on your credit report you know
does it not when you don't pay it does
all good everyone with over ten thousand
dollars in debt qualifies and there's no
minimum credit score required bad and
Fair Credit accepted but it sounds
perfect did they give a CL
sure did PDS is giving our qualified
viewers a free debt analysis just for
completing the 30-second online
assessment at
www.pdsdebt.com files all right
you got it all right
all right I can't wait to tell Gertie
this will make her saggy hump nice and
perky good to hear and maybe she'll
start walking in a straight line again
she already fell in the pool twice she
fell wait I don't have a pool you can't
have an oasis without a pool I really
don't want you to dig up hang on a sec
hey Mary
project now
[Music]
ah
in 1858 zoologist Philip Slater made a
name for himself in the scientific
Community he divided the world into six
geographic regions based on the
distribution of animal species they were
pale Arctic Ethiopian Indian
australasian knee Arctic and neotropical
Slater's system is still used today
while Slater created his classification
system a mystery emerged the fossils of
lemurs
lemur fossils were found in parts of
South America India Africa and
Madagascar these areas are not connected
by land but lemurs don't swim the
question haunted Slater how did lemurs
spread across the world identical
species don't develop in different
places at once he had a radical answer
that there was a landmass once
connecting these areas it would need to
be massive bigger than Australia his
theory was a stretch but it would solve
the Mysteries he'd stumbled upon along
with the unexplainable locations of
lemurs Slater also uncovered extreme
similarities between monkeys found in
South America and Africa in 1864 Slater
published an essay about his theory in a
scientific journal in the essay he
refers to his proposed continent as
lemuria
anterior to the existence of Africa in
its present shape a large continent
occupied parts of the Atlantic and
Indian oceans
stretching out towards what is now
America to the west and to India on the
east in Madagascar and the masquerine
islands we have existing relics of this
great continent for which as the
original focus of the sterps lemurum I
should propose the name lemuria
this land bridge concept was popular in
the scientific community at the time Sir
Charles Lyle a well-known geologist and
teacher believed continents were Rising
above and sinking below the ocean
routinely just very gradually so it's no
surprise that following the publication
of Phillips glader's essay the lemoria
theory really caught on it turned out
lemuria may have been the answer to many
scientific mysteries in fact lemuria may
have been the birthplace of humanity
itself
in 1864 Phillips glader introduced the
concept of lemuria to the world 24 years
later Helena blavatsky a Russian
theosophist and co-founder of the
theosophical society published a book
titled the secret Doctrine theosophists
like blavatsky are truth Seekers who
study a combination of religion science
and philosophy they believe in an
ancient wisdom that unites all major
religions the secret Doctrine discusses
the origins of humanity it outlines a
sequence of seven root races
representing different stages of human
development currently we are in the
fifth stage with the sixth and seventh
Yet to Come according to the secret
Doctrine and other writings by
blavatsky's followers the first root
race was ethereal and didn't possess
physical bodies they may have appeared
as giant Phantoms the second root race
was shapeless and asexual asexual well
they didn't engage in sexual activity
they reproduced through a process called
budding which is essentially natural
cloning the third root race thrived in
lemuria and coexisted with Dinosaurs
according to theosophist W Scott Elliott
these lemorians were giants
his stature was gigantic somewhere
between 12 and 15 feet his skin was of a
yellowish brown color he had a strangely
flattened face eyes small but piercing
and set curiously far apart so that he
could see sideways as well as in front
the head sloped backwards and upwards in
a rather curious way the arms and legs
especially the former were longer in
proportion than ours early in the
Lemurian period the supposed human
ancestors laid eggs but over millions of
years their reproductive process
developed into well the one that we know
today edit process has gotten me in a
lot of trouble over the years well maybe
you shouldn't have engaged in the
process as much as you did yeah
and her followers weren't the only
people who wrote about the lemorians a
few years later British writer James
churchward started writing about the
sunken continent of Mew at first Mew was
thought to be the inspiration for
Plato's story of Atlantis but churchward
connected it to lemuria and now many
consider these lost continents one and
the same James churchward's work is
based on the translations of ancient
Indian tablets these texts are included
in a series of books called the children
of Mew tablets describe an ancient
civilization of 60 million people that
was eventually destroyed according to
churchward and others like archaeologist
Augustus Le ponjon the sunken continent
of Mew once stretched from Hawaii in the
north to Easter Island in the East and
almost reached Japan in the west the
yanaguni monument off the coast of Japan
is believed to be the underwater ruins
of this Lost Civilization Nan madal and
Micronesia is considered the southern
part of Mew the site contains structures
made of large volcanic rock logs it's
unknown who built them or how but the
society was Advanced recent lidar
Imaging revealed an artificial
irrigation system that provided fresh
water to Residents throughout the area
they even had a sewer system years
before the ancient Greeks or other
Advanced civilizations Easter Island
marks the Eastern point of Mew take a
look at Easter Island
[Music]
it's a small island in the middle of
nowhere yet it was once home to 12 000
people how did they get there mainstream
science says they traveled thousands of
miles across the Pacific Ocean in canoes
but if the continent of new existed they
could have just walked there this could
also explain the similarities between
Polynesian languages and Greek as well
as the worship of a sun god named Raa on
Easter Island which is similar to the
Egyptian Sun God Ra these similarities
of language and religion suggest that
these cultures either intermingled or
originated from a common source James
churchward Le plan John Helena blavatsky
they all described lamoria immune
differently but there's one thing they
all agree on it was destroyed in a
terrible cataclysm
Chan Thomas in his book The Adam and Eve
Story presents compelling evidence that
Global disasters occur in a cycle
lemuria might have been destroyed during
one of these events according to James
Bramwell and William Scott Elliott
supporters of this theory lemuria was
destroyed 11 500 years ago in a global
disaster and evidence of a global
cataclysm can be found all over the
Earth from the Pyramids of Giza across
Africa and even on Easter Island now of
course I'm referring to the great flood
mentioned in the myths of every culture
on Earth the flood that occurred during
a period of History called the younger
dryas as the last ice age Drew to a
close the massive ice sheets that had
covered much of the northern hemisphere
began to rapidly Melt Away Great
torrents of fresh water poured into the
oceans causing sea levels to rise
dramatically across the globe
what
coastal areas were transformed by the
flood as shorelines expanded Inland by
hundreds of miles entire land masses
were submerged beneath the rising Seas
the lives of every human on earth were
disrupted by the great flood entire
cultures that had been tied to the old
shorelines were shattered and Scattered
but a few resourceful people survived
and rebuilt their civilization
but this time they did it in secret and
hidden far away from any future Global
catastrophe but what caused the ice
sheets to melt in the first place
there's disagreement about this some
think it was the impact of a massive
Comet or asteroid others think it was a
solar event so destructive that plasma
from the Sun Stripped Away the Earth's
magnetic field exposing the planet to
extreme heat and radiation or a pole
shift which would also create a
worldwide disaster but there is one
Legend of lemuria that contains a
different explanation that the great
flood wasn't caused by an asteroid or
the sun it said that the great flood was
caused by people
[Music]
according to blavatsky lamoria was
destroyed by fire volcanic eruptions
shattered the continent into Islands
slowly the island sank into the sea
along with blue marine history
James Church Ward's version of the
sinking of Mew is more dramatic and
immediate
the civilization was obliterated in a
single night of Terror intense
earthquakes shook the land volcanic
eruptions spewed fire and Ash Relentless
tsunamis engulfed the entire continent
it was a catastrophic event in one night
everything was gone there are even
speculations that the lemurians were
eradicated by a pole shift a sudden and
civilization-ending event
churchwards depiction resembles this
cataclysmic shift volcanoes erupting
around the world simultaneously massive
waves flooding everything an entire
civilization wiped away in an afternoon
others proposed something even more
chilling the destruction of lemuria was
not natural at all they believe it was
intentional
there is a ten thousand year old story
which appears in books like the
Chronicles vacacor which says the Lost
continents of lemuria and Atlantis sank
due to a nuclear war caused by the
Anunnaki
the Anunnaki or deities of the ancient
Sumerians acadians Assyrians and
Babylonians and some consider the
Anunnaki and alien race who created
humans through DNA manipulation then
used humans as slaves a full Anunnaki
episode is coming up
[Music]
The Chronicles of aquacor tells the
story of two hostile Divine races that
eventually went to war the four corners
of the earth were red
the two races of gods started to dispute
in JJ benitez's book The Visitors he
recounts the Alien Abduction of a
scientist Daniel W Frey on July 4th 1959
while fry was on the alien vessel they
told him that they were the descendants
of race who lived on the land of Mew
they said there was another Advanced
civilization on Earth that we call the
atlanteans Edgar Casey also received
telepathic messages about Atlantis he
described their culture and their
technology
in our great City we harness the
firestone's energy through advanced
mechanics our domed power station
concentrated the stones Rays via prisms
this energy propelled our crafts through
induction similar to your remote radio
control though invisible the raise
powered vehicles through the air on land
and sea carefully aligned the Stone's
forces regenerated human bodies and
fueled Industries
Casey also predicted that Atlantis would
eventually be discovered
the position as the continent Atlantis
occupied is that as between the Gulf of
Mexico on the one hand and the
Mediterranean upon the other evidences
of this Lost Civilization are to be
found in the Pyrenees and Morocco on the
one hand British Honduras Yucatan and
America upon the other the British West
Indies or the Bahamas
a portion of same that may be seen in
the present if the Geological Survey
would be made in some of these
especially or notably in Bimini and in
the Gulf Stream through this vicinity
these may be even yet determined now
keep in mind that it was 1939 when Edgar
Casey predicted that Atlanta would be
discovered in Bimini in the Bahamas the
Bimini Road wasn't discovered until
1968.
according to Casey and others atlanteans
live peacefully on Earth for over 200
000 years but then the Anunnaki started
to influence and corrupt the leaders of
Atlantis the corrupted atlanteans known
as the sons of Belial initiated a
conflict with lemuria about 25 000 years
ago Atlantis and lamoria disagreed on
how to rule the Earth Atlantis wanted to
dominate all tribes and civilizations
worldwide but the lemurians wanted the
Earth's civilizations to develop on
their own so they ordered Atlantis to
leave them alone Atlantis refused
lamoria insisted Atlantis chose War
the beginning of the war was the year
ten thousand four sixty eight BC in his
writing Plato mentions 9500 BC as the
year that Atlantis was destroyed an
ancient historian named Hamas reports a
terrible catastrophe that occurred in 11
000 BC but how were these civilizations
destroyed well the atlanteans had
extremely advanced technology and
weapons their Technologies and weapons
were beyond what we know today
flying crafts powered by fire crystals
traversed the skies great energy beams
harvested from the Earth itself fueled
weapons that could level mountains
lemuria was not as well armed and could
not avoid war
they burned the world with solar heat
and tried to draw energy from each other
rivers have been changed and the height
of the mountains and the strength of the
Sun have changed there have been
continents that have been flooded in the
end more than 60 million lemurians died
the survivors took refuge in agartha and
later attacked Atlantis the Earth became
unstable as a result of nuclear
explosions and because of that the
Earth's axis changed and the pole
shifted all that remained of Atlantis
are ancient structures like Stonehenge
and the Great Pyramids the civilization
of Atlantis did not survive the conflict
but about ten thousand lemurians did
survive and they rebuilt their
civilization but this time they did it
in secret and that Civilization exists
today thriving
under a mountain in California
foreign
California has become synonymous with
the unknown many who Venture close to
the mountain report strange events
blowing orbs unexplained voices and a
tangible sense of another presence Mount
Shasta is also considered a Vortex a
place where the boundary between
Dimensions is thin Native American
tribes speak of its sacred power a spot
where the spirit world is accessible
then there are the geological Mysteries
why does Shasta have such a complex
structure and so many different kinds of
rock why do some plants grow there that
are found nowhere else where do those
plants come from well Legend has it that
some lamorians survive the cataclysm the
survivors travel to North America and
brought with them plants and animals and
Technology they then built a city
underneath Mount Shasta they call the
city Telos the city of light and
eyewitnesses have described the city in
detail as you approach the hidden
entrance to Telos an energy pulsates
through the ground there is a deep
humming sound and a vibration that you
can feel all over your body
once inside you are enveloped by a soft
light that emanates from the walls of
the city Telos is carved into five
expansive levels each one a Labyrinth of
corridors Chambers and Gardens
the inhabitants of tilos are seven feet
tall and draped in flowing white robes
despite their large size they move
slowly and gracefully they are the
lemurians the Guardians of their ancient
Lost Civilization their technology is
integrated with their natural
surroundings just as it did in lemuria
before the fall in Telos they use
crystal technology large crystalline
structures serve various functions they
have healing chambers that resonate with
frequencies that restore the body and
the Soul they have Crystal communication
devices that allow mental connection
across the entire planet
Transportation within the city is
achieved through levitating platforms
that Glide along magnetic lines Guided
by thought alone at the center of Telos
is the Temple of the heart here a large
Crystal pulses with a heartbeat a rhythm
synchronized with the natural Resonance
of the Earth
residents of Mount Shasta claim to have
seen tall beings wearing white robes
walking at the foot of the mountain
hikers have even followed the beings
into caves but when the hikers finally
get inside the cave it's empty though
some say you can still hear and feel the
humming vibration one eyewitness
actually made the news in the early 20th
century
in 1904 JC Brown a British prospector
was hired by a mining company to search
for gold deposits in Northern California
while investigating around Mount Shasta
he noticed an odd looking piece of rock
that didn't match the surrounding area
as he began clearing the debris and
vegetation surrounding the rock he found
an entrance to a cavern system that led
deep into Mount Shasta Brown walked
about three miles into the interior of
the mountain through an array of
criss-crossing tunnel systems when he
began stumbling across pieces of gold
after the 11th mile he reached a
location that resembled a village inside
the village he came across Chambers
filled with gold and copper tablets he
found statues and Spears and weapons and
he found skeletons the average height of
these skeletons were around six foot six
inches tall and the tallest being 10
feet in height over the next few days he
took pages and pages of notes he
memorized everything that he could and
when he left he covered the entrance so
that no one else would find it and brown
spent the next 30 Years researching and
tried to build a group of experts to
embark on an expedition he finally
gained a following of about 80 people
willing to join the Expedition including
a museum curator and several scientists
he spent six weeks planning out the
entire trip and several individuals sold
off their properties believing that they
would soon become rich
Brown was worried someone would sneak
into the city in advance so he withheld
a lot of the specifics regarding the
location of the cavern system he met
with the team one last time to make
final preparations and established a
time in place of departure June 19th at
1 pm the day finally arrived and JC
Brown didn't show and he was never heard
from again
but the story of lemuria is not only
told in the west the Tamil people
indigenous to South India have a story
of a lost continent that dates back to
ancient times the name Kumari kandam was
applied to this sunken Land The Legend
tells of an early Tamil Dynasty known as
the pandian Kings they ruled over the
now submerged Kamari kandam continent
before it was swallowed by the rising
Seas at the end of the last ice age
younger Witness
according to the stories kumara kandam
was once located in the Indian Ocean
between India and Madagascar this large
continent was the cradle of civilization
home to the first people the pandian
Kings ruled the entire continent from
their Capital City before successive
floods submerged Kamari kandem around 10
000 years ago is this just a Tamiya
legend or is this actual history well
floods at the end of the last ice age we
have proof of that but a lost continent
in the Indian Ocean between Madagascar
and India that's so specific there's no
way there's proof of that is there is
fear is there there is
imagine an ancient tropical land Lush
jungles stretch as far as the eye can
see dinosaurs graze on Treetops high
above the forest floor while early
mammals stalk the dark ground below this
was Marisha a lost world forgotten
beneath the waves in 2013 scientists
announced that they may have found
traces of the Spanish continent deep
under the Indian Ocean it had sunk below
the sea millions of years ago when the
continents were still joined as one
supercontinent back then South America
and Africa hadn't split apart India was
attached to Madagascar and Marisha was
squeezed in between Marisha was
discovered by accident geologists
studying rocks in the island of
Mauritius east of Madagascar were
confused they found minerals too ancient
to belong to such a young volcanic
island as they followed the clues they
found traces of a much older land mass a
huge mass of buried continental crust
stretched across the Indian Ocean a lost
continent matching Ancient Minerals the
researchers named it Marisha after the
island that led to its discovery
but the location of Marisha is exactly
where some Legends say lemuria was
the details of the continent are still a
mystery with more questions than answers
was it really an intact continent or
just a jumbled mass of islands and what
creatures might have lived on this
island and could some of those creatures
have been the very early ancestors of
the lemurians
there's no hard evidence to support the
existence of lemuria or Atlantis
everything we know about these
civilizations comes from stories and
many of those stories come from
unreliable sources like Madame levotsky
James churchward and Edgar Casey Daniel
fry who claimed to have been abducted by
aliens probably wasn't he failed a
polygraph he kept changing his story and
he lied about his scientific credentials
he also got caught hoaxing UFO
photographs so without evidence places
like lemoria the land of new and
Atlantis remain nothing but myths but
The Accidental discovery of Marisha
shows that some ancient legends may be
based in truth the discovery of the
continent of mauritia happened
completely by accident Bimini Road was
discovered by accident so was the
yanaguni monument
[Music]
dwarka is described in ancient Indian
texts as a magnificent city that was a
symbol of prosperity
it was described as an advanced
well-planned City with beautiful gardens
and temples and palaces but according to
Hindu Legend thousands of years ago the
Seas began to rise and eventually dwarka
disappeared into the ocean and was lost
forever and for a thousand years the
story of the city of dwarka was thought
to be symbolic
but
in the 1980s the ancient city was found
and is estimated to be around 10 000
years old maybe older
in 2001 an underwater Discovery was made
off the coast of Cuba structures were
found that at first were thought to be
natural formations but a submersible
robot was sent to the site and found
what's been described as an entire city
and what makes this find so
extraordinary is that it's about 2 000
feet down scientists have said it could
take 50 000 years for a city to sink
that far even if it's not that old there
are blocks down there that are thought
to be at least 6 000 years old but
nobody can say for sure
all of these discoveries were made by
accident and as long as people keep
exploring the sea there's a chance that
Atlantis and lemuria might eventually be
found and if we actually excavate the
sites off India and Japan in the East
and Cuba and the Bahamas in the west we
may realize that Atlantis and lemuria
have already been found
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ that's hacklefish
hey what's buzz and sexy cousin this has
been the wire files if you had fun or
learned anything do a heck of fish a
favor like comment subscribe share I
know it's annoying to hear us ask that
but it really does help the channel and
like the topics we cover in the Y files
today's is recommended by you so if
there's a store you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and if you need more wi files in
your life because who doesn't check out
the why files Discord there are
thousands of people on there 24 7 and
they're all just a little bit strange
like we are a special thanks to our
patrons who make all this possible I
dedicate every episode to you and I
could not do this without your
generosity but if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon for as little as three
dollars a month you can keep the Y files
going and you also get access to some
cool perks like early access to videos
no commercials Early Access to fun
products like the talking Echo fish
plushie and other stuff or if you'd
rather get stuff check out the Wi-Fi
store
foreign
[Music]
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
shadow people there
and his name was cold
with the
ES
[Music]
foreign
I can't believe
[Music]
zombies
dance with the feeling is
[Music]